the arab or muslim world has been
suffering for a long time as a victim of
violence wars and interventions
history recounts a long record of
conflicts between western and muslim
powers
lane has crashed into the world trade
center
we knew the world would change forever
and that it would be worse for us for
being muslim colonization also was built
on a racial structure
a story of europe being colonized by
arabs
we all can be easily received
the truth
competes with the dollar
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
most of us operate on half truths about
the world the government in the west
have a vested interest to craft a new
enemy more and more
media in the united states is purely
profit driven
is there a conspiracy that keeps the
arab world and the west permanently at
war with each other
east and west a love-hate relationship
whenever it calms down it surely tenses
up again
i grew up in cairo and studied at the
american university there my teachers
were multinational i had friends from
all over the world
when i started working in hollywood i
was quite fascinated by western culture
but i wondered why some people had such
a narrow view of the arab world and of
islam
my first role in hollywood was a
terrorist role
but the film criticized american foreign
policy in the middle east
prejudice came later when i received
many other offers to play similar
terrorist roles
so i decided not to make this my
specialty
in the last two decades or more i have
moved fluently between the western and
arab worlds and i have come to realize
that there is much more that unites us
than separates us
the idea that the west is waging a war
on the arabs and on islam in particular
is actually an old idea
but it gained momentum in the past 70
years
the opposite of this idea also exists in
the form of fear in the west from an
arab or muslim plot to destroy them
some people say that this fear has been
magnified and strengthened on one
particular day i do not
forget on the 11th of september 2001 i
was going back to cairo after i had
received the prize in alexandria
international film festival in the car
driving back with friends i received a
phone call
it's 8 52 here in new york i'm brian
gumbel we understand that there has been
a plane crash plane has crashed into the
world trade center oh my god another
plane has just hit
we knew
we knew that the world will change for
us
because we are muslim
but is the world in disagreement with us
just because we are muslim
i need an answer from someone who
studied this in depth and who knows well
the west and the arab world
heightened
co-founder and professor of islamic law
and theology at zaytuna college
hi hatham
how are you i'm good i'm good how are
you doing i'm doing well i'm doing well
okay i have read your writings about
this topic but i would like to hear it
from you what is the basis for the
theory that there is a war waged against
islam by the western world
we are living through a colonial
post-colonial period colonization
was not only a single event like you go
and watch a soccer game and that's it is
finished colonization is a process
if you think of colonization as one
event then you say well the french left
and the british left and that's it it is
not
how does colonization
fit in this war
colonization also was built on a racial
structure
meaning the superiority of the european
white subject and the sub-humanness
inferiority of everyone else
there's only one epistemology that is
allowed to remain in the world and that
is eurocentricity that the meaning of
the world is only to be
understood within the line of
understanding of eurocentric thoughts so
as a muslim having an islamic
epistemology has cannot be allowed to be
according to your research can you tell
me some of the organizations in the west
that are engaging in spreading
islamophobia
the governments and states in the west
have a vested interest to craft a new
enemy there is a decision that's been
taken especially with the work of samuel
huntington clash of civilization
book he says the following there can be
no true friends without true enemies
unless we hate what we are not
we cannot love what we are
which means that in order to create a
western societal solidarity and a sense
of patriotism
we have to find an object of our hate
so there's that clash of civilization
that gets to be adopted
in the post collapse of the soviet union
and from that point on you shift from
the red scale of the communist world to
the green scare
right in relations to the muslim world
when i came to the west
many seemed surprised that i was
egyptian
i guess that is a normal result of the
images and stories projected by western
mass media about the arabs
but why does western media insist on
projecting these images
to be able to answer this question i
have to talk to someone from hollywood
the american filmmaker james longley who
made a documentary which reflects an
honest picture of iraq
the film is tight of the iraqi fragments
and was nominated for the oscars
there was all kinds of fear-mongering
going on in 2002 in 2003 in the lead-up
to the war
all kinds of things were being said in
the media
that simply weren't true
about iraq in order to convince the
american public to go to war
and the obvious thing to do then as a
documentary filmmaker was to go to iraq
and make a documentary that would tell
the story from the point of view of
iraqi civilians
as a person who has lived in the west
and visited the arab world can you tell
me about
media representations of the muslims in
the west we simply don't make a lot of
stories and show a lot of stories about
ordinary people in places like iraq and
afghanistan so it's natural that
americans not being exposed to the
realities for ordinary people in these
countries we have a big blind spot in
the united states because these are
conflict zones so it's a bit frightening
and we know that if we watch a film
probably it's going to be something
related to
war and death and violence in the real
world and war that we are
involved in somehow ourselves so there's
a bit of a guilt
factor there
[Music]
breaking news do you think that the
media in the west represents muslims
accurately of course the representation
isn't accurate quite often negative
quite often the association is with
violence
and
religious extremism more and more
media in the united states is purely
profit driven these are all big
corporations and they have a
responsibility to their shareholders to
try to make as much money as possible uh
i think you wind up with a situation
where uh the truth competes with the
dollar
in essence what do you think of what
michael moore did publish a photo of
himself holding a sign saying
we are all muslim at that moment when
there's a muslim ban going on
from the trump administration and things
are looking very dire i think michael
moore really did the right thing and the
courageous thing by holding up the sign
and it's really just solidarity he's
saying you know you can't divide us
like that
we're americans and we believe in
something
which is that the united states is a
country for all of its citizens and i
would say it's still true that most
americans do believe in this idealized
version of the united states
[Music]
we have to always ask ourselves do we
have all the information we need is it
really what it seems it can always be
deceived i mean there are powerful
groups in the west that are working to
spread islamophobia and racism but there
are other groups that are working
against it
trying to spread equality sometimes we
could both have the same information
and the information would be accurate
but we could each deduce something
different from it this is why vulnerable
people and disempowered people are more
likely to believe what explains their
sufferings
we all can be easily deceived
[Music]
the story does not end here
there's another theory i read about in
an article called eurabia which claims
that europe is being invaded by muslims
to understand more about eurabia i'm
talking to the writer andrew brown
journalist in the guardian hi andrew how
are you doing yeah absolutely fine thank
you great i wanted to ask you about
eurabia what can you tell me about this
well eurabia is the name given to uh
what is essentially a conspiracy theory
brought about by
litman developed a theory which combined
two beliefs one about islam and one
about europe now the belief about islam
was that essentially it was a religion
that was deeply intolerant bent on world
conquest and demanded second-rate status
what she called dimitu
of everyone who wasn't a muslim who came
under their rule however given this
vision of islam as a sort of dominating
imperialist ideology that she had she
then wrapped into this a deep suspicion
of
the european union and the french
government in particular and she became
convinced that a plan had been hatched
after the 1973 oil shock by which europe
would gradually hand itself over to
muslim sovereignty in exchange for
unhindered access to arab oil she gave
the name of eurabia to this theory it
was a story of europe being colonized by
arabs whereas in fact i think the arab
and
certainly the egyptian experience was
the other way around all together
[Music]
this is a billboard that was put on the
streets in berlin recently it says vote
so that europe will not become eurabian
how did we arrive here you make your
half-truths out of a few carefully
selected facts and you stick them
together and you pull them out of their
context
and they can mislead anyone most of us
operate most of the time on half-truths
about the world because we haven't got
the time to look into the whole truth we
haven't got the resources i mean i'm a
journalist i spend my life trying to get
around
the other side of a half-truth and it's
very time-consuming
so how did this theory become so
mainstream as to appear on the streets
of such a big capital like berlin her
theory was combined with another piece
of french
anti-arab racism a book called the field
of the saints
which again had come out in the 1970s
originally and
whose thesis was that europe was
threatened by great tides of
brown-skinned immigrants and when you
mix the political
conspiracy theory that was eurabia with
the demographic worry you know the fact
that white european populations are
shrinking and brown populations all
around the world are growing you've got
a very combustible mixture it is called
eurabia and one would think this theory
should be confined to europe but
how did this theory export to the united
states
you know americans uh they were knocked
absolutely sideways by it i was
traveling in america that autumn you
know the television news was just
absolutely crazy
and all of a sudden
huge numbers of americans wanted an
explanation for why this should happen
and in that great surge of wounded
american nationalism there was an
immense market for books and theories
explaining that islam was particularly
dreadful that islam was a death cult but
and some of this took the form of sort
of atheist writings um the so-called new
atheists were a big part of that some of
it just took the form of kind of
excitable american nationalism and then
into that stew came backyard in arabia
[Music]
i have been thinking about what michael
moore said
we are all muslim
he probably meant that there is more
that unites us as humans than separates
us
and maybe the day will come
when we stop fighting between us
when we stop disagreeing on the answers
i learned to open our mind and heart to
the questions
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you